i don't want to spend a ton of time on
this but i do want to just point out
that this nfl football player aaron
rodgers is continuing to spread straight
up baseless coveted disinformation and
the guy is a role model to so many
people you know when i was a kid i read
this book by charles barkley former
basketball player about how
he really shouldn't be a role model he
behaves in certain ways because he knows
he is as a guy who's in sports but that
really these people should not be role
models and that had there was truth to
that in the 90s
it's so much more true today
here is aaron rodgers now on the pat
mcafee show
saying that
the coveted fact checks about do
vaccines work and stuff like that
they're all done by big pharma so you
can't trust any of them i will say i
don't believe that hatred and fear
and
name calling and any of this stuff is
going to get us out of this pandemic
it's going to be love and connection and
actually conversation and debate
and information sharing
and not information sharing that's fact
checked by the same individuals who are
you know running the pharmaceutical
industry he wants information shared
that is not being fact checked that is
fascinating right oh
which is a lot of a lot of the
you know when you when you look into
some of those connections it is
interesting to see some of the
connections between
fact checkers and boards and
this guy thinks he's absolutely
brilliant guys he thinks he's figured
out
the ultimate truth and he even delivers
it in this tone where it's he's not
taking pleasure but we can't have fact
checks from big pharma um the vaccine of
which there have been is it hundreds of
millions or have we gotten to a billion
doses given
the vaccines have been studied
in randomized controlled trials
in all sorts of different countries by
people not associated with big pharma in
the journals they disclose their
conflicts of interest
studies on do masks work they've been
randomized control you know etc etc and
this guy was almost the permanent
jeopardy host and he's going around
spreading this stuff as a reminder here
is the same guy aaron rodgers
admitting he took medical advice from
joe rogan when he got covered and um
even pat mcafee couldn't could couldn't
contain his laughter when that was
mentioned i consulted with
a now good friend of mine joe rogan
right
after he got covered
and i've been doing
a lot of the stuff that he recommended
yeah in his podcasts
and you know on the phone to me
and
i'm going to have the best immunity
possible now
so that's uh that was that um also uh
more recently
he said aaron rodgers said that there
were people
watching the green bay packers and
rooting against the green bay packers
only
because of his vaccination status which
actually may be true
but they're not nor they're not like the
normal football fans there there's no
doubt that there are people
who had no clue who aaron rodgers was
they found out he was saying very
strange things about covet and they were
rooting for him to lose that's not wrong
i think he's right about that because
there were a ton of people
tuning in rooting against us for one
reason and one reason only it's because
of
uh you know my vaccination status
and them wanting to see us lose so they
could pile on and uh
and enjoy and revel in the fact that uh
you know my vaccination status
was uh
you know some sort of reason why
we haven't had success in the playoffs
or whatever it might be some sort of
correlation yeah now i didn't hear that
once so so it's you know there's always
this self-importance to these guys even
just the way that he talks there's this
air of self-importance it's true that
there are some people who
wanted to see aaron rodgers lose because
they think he's a prick
i mean that's the long and short of it i
have not heard anyone say
that the reason the green bay packers
didn't do better
is because he's unvaccinated just
doesn't it doesn't make any sense i've
not heard anyone say that it doesn't
really pass the sniff test that anybody
would say that and the the really tragic
thing here is
you know we laugh when aaron rodgers
says well the advice i got is from joe
rogan
and even pat mcafee who seems to go with
a lot of the things roger says is like
oh god
um we laugh at that but
there's so many people that don't listen
to doctors and they don't listen to
epidemiologists and they don't listen to
public health officials they listen to
joe rogan and if aaron rodgers wants to
start giving advice about covet
treatment
they'll listen to aaron rodgers as well
and that's the real tragedy of what it
is that is going on here let me know
your thoughts were you rooting for aaron
rodgers to lose because of his vaccine
status
you can let me know on twitter where you
can find me at d pacman and you can also
find me on instagram at
david.pacman we have a great friday show
for you today we will be on the ground
at the trump rally in conroe texas
tomorrow hope you'll be following that
live stream stay with us quick break and
right back
one of our sponsors today is bluechew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time all you have to do is
take a short quiz on their website a
licensed doctor approves your
prescription the medication comes
straight to your home within days in a
discrete package no driving around to
the doctor's office or the pharmacy no
waiting around no awkward conversations
with your doctor all of blue chews
tablets are made in the usa the entire
process is just a few clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping